if anyone has issues with the findings
they should wait for the scientific
paper and raise those issues but not
before that because if they say it must
be a stone when it actually is iron that
makes most of the material then I would
call it the Stone Age of science meaning
everything in the sky is stones and just
think about it if they work on shown the
data on dark matter that we have they
would try to fit it with stones and
suggest not enough matter and say that
data must be wrong clearly that's the
wrong conclusion I'm intrigued by facts
by anomalies and I want to find more
data so that we can substantiate the
meaning of those anomalies that should
not make anyone sick because otherwise
you are behaving like a faith-based
professional someone who knows the
answer in advance and gets sick whenever
the evidence proves otherwise